o
boa tarde gostaria de convidá-los para
reflexão reflexão sobre educação e
gostaria de começar apresentando minha
turma de cálculo um cálculo uma
disciplina que é dado no primeiro
semestre dos cursos de engenharia de
exatas e que é caracterizada por ser uma
disciplina com alto índice de reprovação
são e sem turmas numerosas a minha turma
ela é gigantesca uma turma com 250
estudantes e aí eu proponho um desafio
como que nós poderíamos fazer para que o
primeiro estudante da primeira fileira e
o último da última fileira tivesse o
mesmo nível de interesse de motivação de
engajamento é que não fosse simplesmente
uma aprendizagem mecânica que é
facilmente esquecida mas aprendizagem
significativa abrangente e duradoura
então eu gostaria de mostrar aqui
to
essa mesma atividade tem prosseguimento
do lado de fora do auditório lá então as
nossas metodologias nossas aulas sempre
seguem um curso de aprendizagem ativa e
algumas delas têm maior destaque o renda
derivada por exemplo é uma oportunidade
de aprendizagem pelo erro
os alunos e um professor trocam de lugar
então os alunos vão o quadro responder
ou trabalhar questões de forma
colaborativa e aprendem com os erros e
acertos do grupo outras atividades podem
ver que é um pouco diferente
nós chamamos de suma aí é uma aula de
exercícios outros quem faz as questões
que propõe as questões são os próprios
estudantes por meio de vídeos criativos
em muitos deles nós temos celebridade lá
é rafinha bastos
obrigado pelas palmas em suma é sua mãe
errei ao integral de quatro de quatro
vezes e cantina secante ao quadrado de 2
de 2 x 1 eu não faço a menor idéia do
que isso significa mas você sabe por que
vocês tiveram tempo para se dedicar a
isso
qual é a causa
então a gente conseguir o engajamento
uma melhora maior dos estudantes às
aulas mais interessantes nós tínhamos um
índice de aprovação é relativamente bom
e foi a gente todo mundo satisfeito os
alunos que reprovavam ficavam felizes
alguns que aprovavam muito mais os
professores mostram satisfeitos só foi
vendo um filme no final de ano com minha
família minha esposa minhas filhas eu
descobri que o caminho era a poucos
passos ainda iniciando esse caminho
nesse filme meus amigos papai noel
entrega presente pra todas as crianças
do planeta
esquece apenas uma e aí um elfo chegou o
papai noel e diz
papai noel vocês que são crianças eu amo
ser criança nenhuma percentualmente isso
é nada
aí eu volto a perguntar uma criança não
importa
meus amigos uma criança não importa eu
descobri que deveria importar mais com
os meus estudantes só para você entender
isso é pra entender o contexto de onde
surgiu essa nossa metodologia
eu gostaria é uma coisa que a gente faz
o primeiro dia de aula que vocês olhar
sem rapidamente para a pessoa que está
do seu lado só da pessoa que está do
lado rapidamente olharam um dos dois não
vai passar
pô
parece engraçado mas é trágico é o mais
trágico é que os professores consideram
esses índices de reprovação de 50 por
cento que no brasil e no mundo nessa
disciplina normal
eu não acredito que seja normal e foi
justamente olha lá nós formávamos
formavam formávamos um grupo de 250
alunos mais um grupo de professores que
os auxiliavam nos dias dos eventos mais
um grupo de estudantes voluntários
estudantes veteranos e formamos um grupo
próximo a 300
e foi justamente de uma única cena de um
filme nada pedagógico vocês já viram que
surgiu a nossa metodologia mais recente
os 300 é um grupo de soldados espartanos
que ganhavam em batalha de soldados
muito mais numerosos e dezenas de
milhares e um dia um cidadão espartano
ele chega para o rei fala leônidas eu
gostaria de entrar por grupos 300 eu
treinei isso a minha vida inteira ele
coisa boa então faz um ataque
ele pega uma lança e faz um ataque ele
fala excelente ataque bom agora levanta
esse escudo
só que ele esse cidadão ele possui uma
corcunda monstruosa levando o escudo
levando a não consegue
você não vai poder participar dos 300
porque não porque nós somos uma unidade
impenetrável
por que um soldado espartano não se
defende
ele defende o soldado que está ao seu
lado
quando eu falei olha a pessoa que está
do lado e disse um dos dois não vai
passar provavelmente pensou esse cara tá
lascado
eu vou passar e é por isso que tem um
alto índice de aprovação nesse semestre
eu garanto para vocês não haverá uma
reprovação por que você não vai se
defender
você vai defender a pessoa que está do
seu lado e foi assim que surgiu essa
metodologia funciona basicamente assim
os alunos realizam uma prova
e aqueles que tiverem rendimento ruim
eles têm o direito de refazer a prova
desde que se reúnam um grupo que tenham
alunos que saíram bem alunos eram mal e
as atividades são intensas
liderados por um aluno que são muito bem
que não pode refazer a prova não pode
melhorar sua nota refazendo a prova mas
ele melhora a sua nota se a pessoa que
ele ajudou a melhorar também o índice de
melhora foi significativo foi cerca de
40% em média considerando os ajudantes a
melhora não foi tão significativa foi
cerca de 15% mas esse nunca foi o nosso
objetivo
o objetivo era olhar para o lado e olhar
pessoa que está ao seu lado e analisando
as pessoas foram ajudadas
a melhora foi absurda foi cerca de cem
por cento considerando o quadro geral de
notas
o azul é o normal e o vermelho é o
acréscimo com os 300 nós verificamos que
hoje em dia deixar de fazer os 300 seria
um erro um erro fatal para a cerca de
agente melhorou de 50 para 85% de
aprovação ea gente continua se
preocupando com cada um deles
só que também esse é o objetivo o
objetivo educacional é fazer com que
nosso estudante um cidadão olhe para a
pessoa que está do seu lado
e aí nós fizemos um questionário aberto
onde estudantes poderiam expressar o seu
sentimento em relação a essa metodologia
um dos alunos uma vez tirou 10
ele era um líder de um grupo de trabalho
mais qualquer outro e eu disse você vai
participar dos 300 que não podia
melhorar a nota
ele falou é claro que vou só que no
olhar dele dizer outra coisa ele falava
assim porque estamos fazendo essa
pergunta eu não estou aqui nos 300
para melhorar minha nota eu estou aqui
porque o meu colega precisa de mim
roger já nos ensina
nós nascemos homens mas precisamos
aprender a sermos humanos
esse estudante coloca uma forma muito
interessante foi como reaprender a
aprender essa idéia não é só a aprovação
por ela pela aprovação
um dia eu acordei com uma ideia absurdo
costumo fazer assim e aí não sei o que
aconteceu que eu tive uma ideia estranha
da aula de matemática sem ser convidado
em um local improvável na rodoviária do
gama
eu falei poxa eu quero dar uma aula no
estilo renda derivada da rodoviária do
grêmio abriu o quadro e começa a aula
pra mim acontece com os usuários não é
com estudantes e aí eu fui atrás de uma
voz consciente que negasse isso eu
cheguei pra minha turma dos 300 e falei
quem vai comigo todos sem exceção
levantar a mão e foi uma experiência
magnífica as pessoas paravam pessoas com
deficiência entrava no meio das pessoas
não têm prioridade passava e assistir à
aula e eu acreditava e acreditava errado
do nosso objetivo enquanto professores
era transformar os nossos alunos em
áreas que voassem alto e que não fossem
atrás de objetivos pequenos mas lendo
victor hugo victor hugo nos diz o
seguinte a águia voa mas o rouxinol
canta a águia domina o espaço o rouxinol
conquista a alma então não for não vamos
fazer vamos nos interessar em fazer
águas mais águas que cantam que dominem
a ciência do minicom propriedade com
profundidade mas que dominem com arte
com paixão com solidariedade
esse é o nosso projeto 300 muito
ligado na prova